hello welcome to the CEO play
international Spartacus 77 okay who is
that
nope no name okay let's see don't want
to play the BOGO again I need some I
need some new ideas in my openings
really something new to try ok catalana
this is not very exciting going for the
closed variation here with the bishop
and check inserted at choice a very
decent reputation so let's see what we
can get p6 to Eagle 93 I think Bishop a6
is an idea let's see
you have a taking see form let's see
what he does about that
nothing yeah this is often quite an
interesting idea I'm just playing for
sacrifice I'm not sure about it at this
particular position though we'll see
okay by Tiki five probably know if I'm
still having the rook attacked so what
is this idea with all that caiman let's
let's protect us from the moment he
might play Bishop at 492
I'm back yes sorry for the for the
interruption I got a important phone
call that I had to take and but I still
don't want to just scrap this game okay
I'm a pawn up here and let's see I mean
here's some compensation though let's do
it like this
he's got the total bishop hair which is
always a little bit of an annoyance okay
I couldn't III maybe just try to trade
some stuff I should be better I think
should be better then there was an
interesting sequence I'm sorry for not
doing any the commentary they are led to
answer the phone call and I also didn't
want to terminate the video so what's
this I'm going to take and see get out
of the pin now came the Knights do have
pretty active positions so I'm pretty
happy with this okay so you're saying I
don't have any good discovery probably
true but still try to be an annoyance
iam
somewhere else I don't know I need to
speed up a little bit during the phone
call I had to wasn't exactly
sophisticated what I could do them so
okay
it looks like I should win some stuff
here as a mom is a check though okay
shooting from Knight f3 I don't really
see how I win material it looks like I
should but I just don't see it I maybe
look narrow before I can take c3
okay would be easy to do especially
considering the time
hmm I'd see I Bishop c4 could be an
issue here didn't see this quickly and I
can take it tonight morning yeah I
wasn't totally sure how good this is to
be honest because he gets the a pawn bit
of a problem
check yeah it's always not touristy
tricky check because the Knights are
simply not good pieces to deal with the
person I shoot I've bought this bloody
game again from a completely winning
position
check
I mean I've seen rain chances to draw
yeah but check
check
probably not shame check check check
oh okay man
she was just wanted of course but
somehow God God gifted to draw him I
mean yeah okay so let's have a look at
some of this feels kind of incomplete
because of the phone call and it was
also a little bit it was lost I was
losing lots of time there with this call
anyway so he sacrifices pawn which quite
often can be interesting I'm not quite
sure about this here if this really
gives you and enough compensation each
form yeah often and helpful move for
ninety five ideas I just played aged six
kind of automatically and the engine
wants to play you five and says I'm a
lot better already
hmm yeah yeah it makes quite some sense
if we look at this here I'm getting this
back probably and have ideas like this
or Queen b6 looking at the square yeah
that is probably the idea that gives me
a good position but okay this is also
very much better for black
so what happened here 1996 X takes 93
years it's stronger than mine move I
just grabbed the pawn in 93 yeah
just using those those pieces and
probably not I can just take it oh sorry
through P 426 probably the anti black is
two pawns up for no compensation yeah
well I just had to play a couple of
moves well while making this phone call
anyway I'm a pawn up here and I don't
really think it's enough compensation so
here we got to this this ending the
other map might I'd see a reasonably
active so it should be should be quite
okay so all this looks fairly normal to
me III yeah this is not easy now I had
to go back and somehow is getting
something active going yeah an idea
three is suggested by the comp I saw
this move but Jack I didn't quite saw
why it is so great
I cannot take with the rook this is the
problem I didn't see that one
I mean this is the problem
I also cover this so and then then this
is very strong Knight f3
yeah and now this is the problem in 92
it looks very tempting but he gets the a
pawn and this is very difficult to play
maybe I should have just avoided this
just go back yeah I wasn't sure I had
one minute on the clock I kind of had a
bad feeling about this but um
in some way you don't want to get away
want to want people to get away with
this because it clearly had not
calculated that he can say seven and
whatever he just played it should be
true and thought okay it's a pin but
this is not turn this is not that great
here really now I shouldn't that I
should just play didn't write back and
see if I can win this position with the
extra pawn not sure that I can but it
was it was a lot better than allowing
this which is probably objectively not
great and also a lot easier for wide to
play which is which is important I mean
I get the nights over them and somehow
managed to get the sacrifice in
challenge him I'm objectively probably
losing probably losing him check the
engine says it's a draw after this might
have six check yeah because of the game
I was happy to get rid of the call
because there was so much down on time
okay well I had to make middle of the
game okay I hope you still enjoyed this
this this video thanks for watching